I went to a soccer bar a football bar if  you will a football club we went there  to watch the Morocco  maybe Pepe Chelsea used to playing you  know and I saw my Moroccan people I saw  Moroccan people there I saw my North  Africans there and they were so [ __ ]  happy about this Victory it was  unbelievable I was taken aback man  everything you could possibly take into  I was except one thing I wasn't taking  them around it felt like something was  missing they asked me they go so do you  want to go to Qatar to watch the World  Cup I said I don't need to be a guitar  it's Qatar in it I want to be the people  that are going to be moved by Victory or  defeat yes so you know what we're gonna  do boys we're going to [ __ ] Morocco  boys  foreign  [Music]